and at last check none of them are
republicans
anthony yes very conspicuous ed thank
you for more on the president's
primetime address let's bring in cbs
news chief washington correspondent
major garrett major good morning
as ed just said the president the vice
president key officials are set to hit
the road to sell this plan
why do they feel the need to do this to
maximize the meaning of the money really
to let everyone know that there is real
money to benefit american lives right
now
in the american rescue plan now there's
kind of a narrative going on that
president obama back in 2009 when his
stimulus was passed didn't go out and
sell the plan
we all remember the term we may remember
the term shovel ready projects well they
weren't really shovel ready and
president obama didn't go out across the
nation to aggressively tout
the potential benefits of that well this
president is
to counter what he believes was a
mistake for his
former boss president obama and the real
difference is anthony
a stimulus check is not a shovel ready
project a tax credit for your child is
not a shovel ready
project that's real money that's going
to land in your bank account in the case
of a stimulus check in a matter of days
and a tax credit for your child as early
as july and this is something that will
give
the biden white house the ability to say
not only am i traveling but the money is
real and you can see it
as ed also noted this may the first
major piece of legislation from the byte
administration
passed with no republican support what
do you think the significance of that is
major what does it mean for for biden
virginia down the road
well it's a very important moment
because partisanship sometimes gives you
a window into where politics currently
are the biden white house and
congressional democrats believe the
politics for the american rescue plan
will be universally positive
that this will boost the economy
accelerate vaccines and improve testing
contact tracing
and vaccine development in case we need
other vaccines to deal with these
variants
republicans are saying no we're going to
replay the book of 2009 when they all
oppose
president obama's stimulus and retook
the house in the next midterm election
that's the playbook they're playing
democrats in the biden white house
believe they're rewriting the playbook
with a better plan more aggressive and
more tuned to the needs of the economy
and this virus and that is a very
clarifying moment now the nation knows
who's on which side democrats on side of
the american rescue plan republicans
against it they'll make a decision in
the midterm elections
as we saw the president made a point of
calling out attacks on asian americans
and saying
they must stop major why is that
important why did he put that in this
speech
because the numbers are an epidemic and
that is not an exaggeration the
statistical numbers of the incidences
not only violent ones
but of shunning of screaming of spitting
at people fellow americans being
attacked by their own americans people
who don't
have any other country but america but
look asian or have an asian
ethnicity in their background maybe two
or three generations ago
are being attacked in this country
they're suffering psychologically in
addition
to all the other suffering that we're
doing because of the pandemic it is a
real problem